what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to i
name this series
and watch me change people from liberal
to conservative in real time
like last video right
listen you did well i wasn't expecting
what what i got so let's see my opinion
can be fully swayed with the end of the
video so guys today we're reacting to
thomas sowell as you guys know that is
vital red pill content but before we
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
while you're at it guys we just launched
a facebook page go follow us on facebook
and sign up for our memberships for
exclusive behind-the-scenes content and
tell them about your podcast so you can
catch me the domino fit podcast where we
discuss all things current masculinity
is coming back and all that seems so you
want to hear more obviously we had poe
the recent episode as well so when that
drops that's going to be a fire one so i
was like when does it drop a couple
weeks i think
you're holding it back we're not holding
it back but we got a little like restore
stuff that's to come out first oh okay
okay what obviously i thought i'd be hot
off the press
but you know what you gotta say the best
for last that okay 100 okay every time
should i be offended
definitely not it was a very good
episode a little bit one of the better
ones one of the better ones yes yes you
came over there the what one of the
better ones what it's the best one
like so much in the unconstrained vision
it assumes that we have a power that we
do not have
cannot have and never had to have had
yeah
in england there was a man named skarman
who was saying for the now we must do
this in order to order and in many
countries these pr these programs are
set up with an actual cutoff date
so it was set up with in malaysia with a
cutoff date i think of around
1990 and in pakistan i it was like it
was supposed to go for 10 years
none of those
cut-off dates has meant
a thing these programs not only continue
they increase they spread
so the idea that you can control for the
future
because of these wonderful sounding
words
i can't think of a country in the world
where that's ever happened
in the case of pakistan they did have an
absolute
actual cut-off date
and because the people in east
whatever pakist reason way behind the
people in west pakistan and so there's
these preferences for east pakistanis
now before time for this thing to expire
the east pakistanis uh cc from pakistan
and formed a new nation of bangladesh
that's right and the preferences
continued right on
because there were other groups that had
been added to it and so once you get the
constituency you can't say no to them
i see
it it is an argument that that
has never worked out anywhere that i've
been able to to check all right so tom
sol says no to the welfare state no to
affirmative action
what is to be done and now you were kind
enough to share with me
uh the galleys of your forthcoming
edition of discrimination and
disparities let me give you a few
quotations from
some of the the new chapter in that book
quote
the poverty rate among black married
couples has been less than ten percent
every year do you believe in welfare i
do
how much not much i think
there needs to be a spectrum um issues
liberal
i believe there should be a spectrum for
the most deprived um but i think it
should be highly scrutinized
there should be a very very um stringent
process for those who should
be able to get welfare just so that
people aren't being completely left back
i think it should be for people that are
disabled okay but like actually disabled
now like in the u.s it's pretty easy to
be disabled yes
and it should be for people with really
low iq but i think if you're able-bodied
like i don't is the iq thing really
excuse though because although you have
low iq if you do apply yourself you can
i think there's uh there's a small
subset of the population that their iq
is so low
like
special needs type you know what i'm
saying
like that type of thing i think
i could see the argument for welfare
but
like the majority no so we agree that it
should be more stringent it should be
more mm-hmm
this should be more focused as opposed
to
you know just give whoever oprah you get
well for her you get lost
blackberry i can do that okay you see
that's iowa okay well you are you are
changing your mind well maybe you're
being liberal i'm not
ever whatever
since 1994 as far back as 1969 young
black males whose homes included
newspapers magazines and library cards
had similar incomes to those of their
white counterparts
academic outcomes show a pattern of
disparities similar to the pattern of
disparities
in the amount of time devoted to school
work
apparently
lifestyle choices have
consequences yes close quote
so this is the constrained vision once
again welfare state that's government we
don't rely on that
affirmative action government we don't
rely on that
we rely on hard work
we rely on the institution of marriage
that's correct
yes in other words these things i don't
think it's the marriage especially the
library cards as such
it's that there are lifestyle choices
that have been made and the comparison i
made was between if you look at the
poverty rate among blacks uh uh it was a
22 percent and among whites was 11
percent but among black married couples
i think our culture
has gotten rid of the institution of
marriage or like changed it
i think yes it's definitely changed it i
don't think it's got rid of it i think
something like 62 percent of people
still want to get married
um so it's definitely changed because if
you as the generations go
go on
the idea of manage starts marriage
starts to dilute so you can see when you
talk to younger people the idea of
marriage isn't something as important
which
might extend back to the
um conversation about the low marriage
rates especially within the black
community
marriage is the focal point of of growth
of any
um if any people's uh we've only seen
the byproduct of it and we see the the
the
degradation of people as marriages
dwindling in our community
do you think marriage is about love
no but i think that's part of what the
problem is
that we've turned the idea of marriage
into love and i think that's hollywood
to blame this this disney this disney
fairy tale happily ever after
if you if you studied the origins of
marriage it was to
kind of marry two nations or to stop
feuds or to like marry to rich families
it was it was tactical strategic whereas
now
you know we don't you don't have to ask
people's fathers for uh their daughter's
marriage no more and
that was a process that was used to help
women pick the best men because women
can make naive decisions about love etc
etc i told my dad he could pick my
husband really yeah he said that he
doesn't have time for that
yeah i was like i was like dad you could
just pick and then he's like
you're going to blame me if it goes
wrong yeah yeah she doesn't want that
responsibility would you ever have an
arranged marriage
yeah i mean
here's the thing i i'd want like in a
most arranged marriages the girl still
gets the final say yeah okay so but yeah
like i think
i would but i don't think my parents
would do it well it feels like a like a
like a short wagon
why'd you have bikes
just just just the front okay okay sure
if he was short um
how short i'm saying let's say he was
five eight but he was it was a great man
but he kind of told me am i okay okay
question actually like like is this now
or am i in my 18.
ooh look up you're
21. i'm 21 21. and
um i think if if i
i think i'd say now
do you think that could make the right
choice for you do you think your dad has
the correct ideas of the type of man you
foresee yourself
yeah but i think like how i put this i
think sometimes i i think attraction's
important in a marriage like i think you
need to be attracted to the person
you're married to
and i think it might not be important if
the girl's a virgin because she's not
going to know any different okay
so i think it becomes less important but
if you're not a virgin like i think you
know what attraction is and what it is
couldn't you then look like as you got
to know the guy a bit more can you learn
to be attractive because one thing i see
between men and women obviously what men
are are more visual i'd argue
um so if a man doesn't have any interest
in you he's not ever gonna have an
interest in me whereas a woman
a guy can be ugly but if he takes other
biological boxes either he's well
endowed financially or
um like the sexy sons theory whatever um
you can learn to go you can grow
attracted to him so don't you think
that's something you could
i mean like what's he look like what's
he look like
i don't i don't think i think there's a
bare minimum that you have like that you
have to get over a certain threshold for
a girl to be attracted to you like
that's what one third of the poppy male
population doesn't reproduce
so i i think there's a minimum
so it depends if he's over that like
minimum threshold hopefully that's a
good eye boy
i don't know dad
hey listen what about you what about
okay vice versa okay go ahead and i know
i know men and women aren't the same yes
so
your mom and your dad hook you up with
the
she she's got all the wifey qualities
and no no you don't think she's ugly
okay
you think she's okay but like on on your
skill scale of like girls you could get
she's towards the bottom yeah like
because like ugliest girl you hooked up
with that's where she's at
no
the thing is yeah
i know the type of woman my parents
would want for me okay i need personally
i want to go over a bit of a backbone
um
but mom would i know my mom and dad
would pick up like an actual doormat
like a doormat literally and i i just
got to do it so do you like girls that
are a little mean to you
no i want to say mean but like
i need i need some energy you need
something i need something i need some
excitement
but i know for a fact if my parents
picked my wife and i said yes i just
cheat first my love
and the type of woman they would pick
would probably accept it
so it could be a woman that's not the
dream isn't that every guy's dream but
it's like you want to come home
excitement poor wife again hopefully
i can go back to
just live outside
he's for the streets yeah i feel like
this is like our answers is why marriage
is [ __ ] up
like i feel like we neither of us gave
good answers no we didn't but
but among black married couples it was
7.5 right so it's not so they not only
do better than blacks as a whole they do
better than whites as a whole
and so it's it's so it's lifestyle
choices similarly with with the results
and the some of these are more
successful charter schools
that uh you have these kids not only uh
meeting but exceeding the national
standards in places like harlem and
bedvis divers in the south bronx
and these are not kids who are
skimming the crown cream they're kids
chosen by lottery
they don't even test them for ability
they don't even look at their academic
records they take them into the schools
and and they and they have hard work and
they make it clear at the outset and
they don't tolerate a lot of nonsensical
behavior
uh and and these kids are doing
incredibly so
tom here
again i think back to the moynihan well
no i think so the moynihan report in 65
and he was very alarmed by uh
the illegitimacy rate of 25 among
african-americans by the way in fairness
to the late moynihan we should point out
one reason he was alarmed by this was
his own his own father had walked out on
the family when he was 10 years old he
experienced what it meant yes to be to
kids to have one parent okay and now
it's all gotten dramatically worse for
whites and hispanics and black for
everybody
and then i think
back beyond that to your experience of
harlem
you drop out of high school and do what
go on welfare start cashing no you went
to work
and you spent some of that money to buy
some inexpensive encyclopedias yeah
and the
harlem was
so
but i feel this uh council it's it's
almost a council of despair
in that that world just seems so utterly
vanished
but so your argument is if if we can
stand up to the welfare state
we can somehow get back to that world
the fam family structure will reassert
itself
that's going to that that's going to be
reconquering the same ground which is
really tough to do
but it can't it can be done
i was i was so lucky i at the time i had
no no clue about all this
i left home uh
at the uh in 1948
uh
many decades later i learned that the uh
unemployment rate among black teenagers
in 1948
16 17 year olds
was uh
9.4
among whites so the same age it was 10.2
percent
so both blacks and white teenagers
had only a fraction of the unemployment
that they have today
uh you were expected to work you were
expected to be able to get a job and
more importantly the jobs were there for
you uh and so and what this is
because of a fluke really the the the
minimum wage law in the united states
fairly understand this act of 1938
uh was passed with specified
rates of pay that you're supposed to get
uh almost immediately uh inflation took
off during the 1940s
so by 1948 those numbers that were in
the law were meaningless oh i see you
know there are other words when i
started out as a western union messenger
the minimum wage was 40 cents an hour i
started out at the bottom at 65 cents an
hour so it was the same as if there was
no minimum wage and this is what
happened you had this
i was so lucky i knew of course i had no
clue about any of this
now now a black kid 20 years later comes
in there
uh they've now they've people have
become compassionate they've raised the
minimum wage so he can't get a job
got it and i don't think it does any
community any good to have a whole lot
of teenage
males
hanging around on the streets with no
job and nothing to do
[Music]
yes i do i believe that you might think
you're helping people but in the long
run you're actually making it worse
and teaching people the proper ethics to
work is very important so i think humans
operate best when they're dealing with
adversity because we're made to overcome
adversity when you give things to humans
on the plate we abuse it and initially
it might look good to say you know what
the welfare state let's help these
people out but in the long run what does
that do to the psychology the physical
well-being the generations that follow
if you don't teach them the proper ideas
the proper ethics of of what it means to
work hard which is what we've done is
it's hardwired into our dnas to work
hard and survive and adapt
but we don't have to do that what comes
next it's just pure laziness and we're
seeing again the consequences of this in
today's society through the welfare
state so i completely agree with that
and especially with the minimum wage it
hurts teenagers the most
you think about unpaid internships
wouldn't be unpaid if there wasn't a
minimum wage law like why does the
government tell me what wage i can and
cannot accept
you ever think about that i haven't like
because it's basically the government
even if i the worker want to take a
lower wage so i can get the job they're
saying no you're not allowed to when
even yeah that makes sense i think
it's it's often a misrepresentation of
the information
because
having the minimum wage seems fair
seems fair but in reality like you said
if i wanted to do work for less
but it still means i get a source of
income plus it builds my my ethics
towards work and your resume and there
is exactly that long term what does that
do for the individual as he develops and
what does he impart on the generations
that follow
it's a similar thing so i can imagine
that kids that are born in the house for
the benefits
would naturally go down the same path of
using benefits i have a lot of friends
who you use loopholes to to get houses
oh they have kids to get houses i think
in the uk yeah you have kids yeah yeah
yeah so like you know what friends do
you have well a lot of people who grew
up people in the states and stuff so
that did i even had the conversation
recently um and he all said he said he
he lived in a two bedroom for that all
his life single parent household
but the reason he lives in the
two-bedroom flat is because
they didn't have a daughter
so he's planning to have a son in the
door so they have a bigger house wow
yeah whereas the peers like myself for
me i grad i work hard to make enough to
buy my own house as that sense of
accomplishment
but if it's given to me then this again
how do you value that most people who
are giving stuff don't value that's why
again if you look at you know athletes
or people in the lottery there's
um because a lot of people don't learn
how to
to use these things that they give them
money that goes quick or comes quick
goes quick yes
because how how can you know the value
of overnight money you can't it's
impossible yeah which is why you should
send a donation if you're in this chat
because we work hard yeah yeah
donation
get it's the camera if you know you know
right
tom so
but
another thought here
you're describing a world harlem the
urban world
gone yeah
you but you made visits when you were
young you knew the south as well didn't
you did you you you went back to the
south when you were young from time to
time i said back to the south because as
i recall you were born in the south yeah
like
new york went to new york yeah uh well i
i think this was courtesy the marine
corps which happened to locate the boot
camp in south carolina but what about
camp lejeune and north carolina okay so
what i'm getting at is you were of the
generation that saw jim crow with your
own question no question
okay
so well here's
let me read you a quotation this is from
an article that got a lot of attention
in the atlantic a couple of years ago
called the case for reparations
by ton nahisi coates
quote
white supremacy is a force so
fundamental to america that it is
difficult to imagine the country without
it reparations is the price we must pay
to see ourselves squarely close quote
and tom sowell who actually saw jim crow
with his own eyes and experienced it
responds how
it would be nice to know his uh
evidence for what he said
just to be old-fashioned about it
uh no it was a rotten system
but i don't know how how we get from
that to reparations
i mean
what we see in the united states in
terms of the bad things you see all
around the world
if you were to give reparations to
everyone whose ancestors had been slaves
i suspect that you would have to give
reparations to more than half the entire
population of the globe
slavery was not confined to one set of
races i suspect that most of the people
who either slaves or slave owners around
the world were neither white nor black
i mean this was this was a universal
curse of the human species africa the
middle east asia
and and it continued elsewhere
long after
uh it was abolished in the western
countries all right let me try is uh
sticking with tonahisi codes
it's shelby talk shelby steel talks
about white guilt
and in tana he's a coach you get almost
the counterpart of that
a kind of
african-american claim against the white
guild
and this seems it
beginning with the abolitionists even
beginning before the civil war
you see almost every generation there's
some expression
that
racism and slavery as shelby calls it
the civ correctly of course the sin of
slavery is so deeply it's something we
still live with how do we expiate it how
do we get past it is there something we
can do to relieve ourselves of this
legacy oh i think you should repeat it
if you were a slave owner i i don't see
any reason why you should feel
differently on the other hand
i can't get over the idea of a
apologizing for what b did
okay even when they're contemporaries
much less when you're when they when one
is dead and the other is alive
all right i mean scalia i remember
saying you know that uh i i i i owe no
man anything
because uh people who look like me
caught did something to people look like
him
okay so just get past it
get to work yeah all right tom sowell's
view is get an education stay married
and do your job
roughly yeah all right
charles murray i'm taking you used to
write a column every so often called
random thoughts on the book
and so i'm giving you a little little
snippets here of the passing scene as in
our final questions charles murray in
his 1984 book losing ground and charles
what do you think about reparations
um for the long results of the idea that
reparations need to be paid in order to
wipe the slave plan
but
i don't know what that would look like
and i don't know if that would really be
the end of
this victim mentality that we've
developed for so many generations
do you know one out of every three freed
slaves in louisiana owned slaves
i know that i didn't know that quite a
few of them did go on a lot of them
fought for the confederacy
so who would have reparations the people
from the north fighting against the
confederacy
you know what i mean i think you're
right but arguably it's at scale plus
the people who the black people who are
slaves
again only copy the framework
that was developed by
the slave boss at the time so arguably
they didn't know that
sorry i bought them from who a white
person could only survive a year
at most in africa without catching
malaria back then
and most of like and a lot of times they
didn't know the atrocities that were
committed in order to get them across
so it's like who owes reparations to who
yeah that's what i've i've had this i've
had this debate before that's where the
argument gets scared because again
um you know black people are capturing
other black people in africa to be sold
on two rights
though the argument i could cover up is
this that notion of corruption obviously
you go over there you corrupt the people
and obviously if you if you like who
corrupted the people so
white people go with africa but they
couldn't survive
yeah those things they would celebrate
there they yeah so that's what i was
saying but to start it wasn't because
white people couldn't survive in africa
for a year without catching malaria like
it wasn't until later in history that
like the vaccines and stuff were
developed so people could really travel
like what time do we need it's kind of
like even the native american population
they were wiped out not due to familiar
what due to like diseases yeah
and that's always the same thing like
even the people that got the slaves like
a lot of them died getting them
because
like people just didn't survive like
that
so so it's kind of like who owes who and
on top of that like if you want to take
another indentured servants and ireland
had a lower life expectancy than slaves
because like they were in horrible
conditions so technically they are
indentured servants
but
like were they really in a better
position
yeah and so it's like who was who
and if you were if you were traveling
right if you immigrated to the u.s and
you're white and you're in the north and
you're drafted to fight against the
confederacy do your reparations
it gets confusing and plus
and this is this is this argument i
guess is specific to the us but like you
mentioned if you start to look at other
countries in like the old slaves
including the uk
again like what does reparations look
like
um so yeah for the longest i was like
yeah reparations reparations but what i
don't know would look like
for me reparations would only be like
you know what we acknowledge this
happened
here's a reimbursement for what happened
now let's start let's start over i'll
start fresh because argument well for
the trustees committee against the jews
they receive reparations and i think
uh jewish people but that's because it
happened at that time exactly
but now it's like
this was hundreds of years ago yeah so
so you're always going to hear the
comparison as to you know if
for their experience
they had reparations
which well they had reparations when a
lot more black people died in that time
period
during slavery why is it so difficult
for america to want to apologize and
then to say here's what
i hear people apologizing all the time
people but you are leaders you want
leaders so i'm saying what i'm saying i
always hear people say like like there's
people that are biased and institutions
that are biased but when i say what
people and what institutions they can
never name any yeah because you can't
dive into it
but if you're going to make an
accusation against something like you
should you should have who it is again
but are you asking to name individual
people or you're asking you like
yeah i'm saying like if you're gonna say
like that there are people that have
profited off of it i want to know what
people and what institutions the people
are white people because you profit off
the fact that you was allowed to develop
for such a consistent time period off
the back of slavery so that you use the
uk foreign as an example came from
ireland you can't find it yeah yeah but
even so if you go to the us as a white
person you're likely to to do better
because you're white than if when you
feel like it's a black person generally
speaking this is a why specific because
your wife why because if the buyer is
intrigued by that you you get to go to
harvard at a lower rate than i do i'm
saying i'm saying i'm serious no you
know like but like if there were like
okay imagine if there was
like um
white only institutions people would
have a fit yes like
why though
why why would they ever fear
why i don't know the reason being
because of um
but like if there's a black only
institution they could totally do that
because black people aren't winning off
because as a consequence of as a result
of slavery that's that summer not
specifically but i'm saying like the
nigerian americans outpace white yes so
so there are black people nigerian
americans what ones that come from
nigeria with america indian americans
those are the best things they're doing
better than everybody
shout out to you
most people weren't born in the u.s yeah
so that frees up i make these examples
my parents would come here and become
homeowners whereas white people are
living for generations you are
so the thing is like they talk about um
so on one of these books talks about
redneck culture i don't know have we
talked about this at all i think we
talked sugar okay so so basically like
certain slaves came from were in a
culture that was really unproductive
and it's it's basically like the rap
culture that you see a lot of the
dialects that they use is like ub you
what like that sort of thing and like
back then 9 out of every ten black
people derive from that culture okay and
one out of every three white people
derive from that culture and so a lot of
that income and like disparities that
you see were very similar in both groups
okay because people tend to discriminate
against that culture but the one out of
every 10 black people that didn't derive
from that culture even back then like
they were outpacing whites
and so it to me it says it's more about
choices and culture than it is about
skin color because the way you like
because if you were going gonna test
right is racism a big factor in america
today what you would do is you would
take two groups that are black and see
if they both have the same results to
test if it's skin color so you would
take indian americans that are darker
than whites right and test do how do
they perform though they also
blow white people are white's performing
the best and they're not
the indian americans are outpacing
whites they're one of the highest
earning income groups in america see
with the argument we take it back as
well but even in or you would take the
two slave colonies so you would take
people that didn't so there was a
different set of slaves that was in the
caribbean and they didn't have that
culture and you would say okay are these
two groups with different cultures same
skin color same history how are they
performing
and since the and because the the
culture
the culture that came from the caribbean
they were outpacing whites and a lot of
like the most successful black people
back then came from that island and
that's why they say it's more about
culture than it is about skin color
and i don't necessarily i don't disagree
with that um but again it's depending on
which groups that you're focused on but
if you're talking more holistically
and i can't remember exactly the time
period but there was a time when black
people were building the enterprise in
the u.s and obviously in order for a lot
of um at the time businesses to be
successful they took learn from banks
and it was known that bikes wouldn't
lend to black people which infringed on
nobody but i heard that was because
their credit scores were lower
collectively
they wouldn't have been any different
from what's being collectively like um
like i i don't the comments can correct
me if i'm wrong they always do but i
heard that it wasn't because of their
skin color it was because like that was
another time where they assumed just
like discrimination was disparity was
discrimination so they got less loans so
they assumed it was discrimination but
when they looked at it was really they
had lower credit scores
we have to agree that i i i don't have
the information to have now in regards
to that but i do know when i did read
that article it was based on solely
discrimination because they did show
that white people
in the same bracket financially while
getting loans once black people work so
i can't argue that doesn't have anything
that your income doesn't have anything
to do with credit
no so yeah credit i use the income so
yeah your credit um yeah that's that's
what if i find it okay
was that was the case so not in all
cases there's different um cases that
factor into different situations so i'm
not gonna i can't argue that with the
two the idea of the two groups put
against each other i think that's
correct but at the same time there were
um biases towards race that infringed on
the ability of black people in the u.s
specifically to progress but like my
question would be what would it like
okay because i could say women weren't
allowed to vote in the 1920s oh oh i'm
discriminated against but in all reality
that has nothing to do with me today
as a woman and so it's like if you
weren't alive for it how does that have
anything to do with someone born in 2022
because they still profit off the
bathroom
how and 88 of millionaires are
self-made i say white people in general
i don't mean i don't mean specific
family specific people i don't like
people in general like why why why do
white people just profit off the backs
of it because of lipidism okay because
but when 88 of millionaires are
self-made what do they do i hire people
who from from uh um
ideological buyers perspective look like
this but i'm saying if your argument's
nepotism right if that's if that's your
argument okay then then you would say
that the majority of met wealth would
not be self-created it would be coming
from nepotism because then
hold on it would be coming from nepotism
but you're kind of moving the goal post
because you said nepotism and i said
okay if the results if if nepotism is
the way that they're profiting off it
where are the results to show for it and
there aren't because 88 percent of
millionaires are self-made
so when i say nepotism okay i mean from
the i don't know specific word place and
how would you how would you account for
people that immigrated the majority of
people in the us immigrated after
slavery
really yes oh my god in the 1900s and
late 1800s because they um like me i
mean i'm from i'm irish german
lithuanian welsh and everyone came in
the last like 150 years
there was a really big influx in the
1900s of people immigrating to the us so
what was the point you make in reverse
of the immigration i'm saying how would
you account like how are they profiting
off of it if they came afterwards
right but i'm saying like what i'm
saying but i'm saying irish right so you
could say like irish people had a had a
lower life expectancy so it's like and
then they went over to the us and that
would have changed because at the end of
the day sometimes there is indentured
servants in the us that were white in
terms of standing
if at the time two people to go for a
job or try to get along et cetera et
cetera the white person would be a
better at more higher advantage of
getting that than a black person
off off the back of the
um
civil war everything
oh you're talking about that or now
do you have evidence that supports that
because there is there are signs that
said irish need not apply and there's
very similar writings in in indiana in
the in the either early 1900s or late
no but i'm saying no i'm saying there's
and same with the italians there's
different groups that also there was
internment camps for the japanese that's
the most recent atrocity there was
literal camps for the japanese but you
never
but like you never hear them talking
about it
no you don't so i i i believe in the
victim intelligence
but obviously when it comes to scale
the scale is different so
i saw how japanese was they had the
japanese come over and don't racist the
japanese would have called him jackson
they did whatever to them i remember
watching documentary regards to that but
when in terms of scale
most these people are able to they're
allowed to do what they need to do but
the difference with the japanese people
is that japanese people from japan have
a culture of hard work
but and this is where i think the slight
difference is but right black people
um they fell into this idea of welfare
this idea that we need reparations to
progress this idea that we need some
kind of support you know to progress
whereas most other cultures in respect
of where they're from just go over and i
think that's the fundamental difference
i don't think we're saying i do believe
there was a there is a racism doesn't
exist i do believe that it sometimes
it's unconscious racism and people do
operate from a um a place of bias um
because there's even a psychological
study that says that
people are more likely to identify
people who look like them
more of the people who don't so based
off that alone if again if we're going
for a job and we both interviewed over
that stage just off your bias alone not
to say that um you're going to let the
job over me but you're more likely off
the back of that
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's where it ends but that's the
thing with capitalism though if you're
discriminating against peace
if you're discriminating against people
based off of race you'll be taken out of
the market yes because like you make the
most money by getting the best skilled
people yes
so it kind of it's all about skill so i
i don't disagree with that either
because
that's that's how the capitalist market
is the structure so even when it comes
to
um the conversation between men and
women as a captain is you want the best
of your company so irrespective where
that person is from this is what you're
gonna do but it's all about skill i
can't argue that um in most cases that
capitalism wins but i can't argue that
in some cases um
more less so now than it was then
um that your race did play a fundamental
part in the ability for that individual
group or demographic to be successful
murray writes about
discussions in academia and government
about the effort to close the gap again
between african americans and whites
quote
1984 quote whites had created the
problem it was up to whites to fix it
and there was very little in the
dialogue that treated blacks as
responsible actors close quote has not
is that available donald trump does not
have the personal character that we
would want our children to imitate but
save his misguided international trade
policies has turned out to be a good
president
tom i think his policies have been by
and large have been uh policies that
were far better than that of previous
democratic or republican administrations
so
look i go by the consequences okay i
mean
he he hasn't produced the right rhetoric
but the fact is that uh
unemployment among low-income people
black hispanic included uh
is a level that is far lower than it's
been in decades
uh
yeah the the the uh
the economy is booming in a way that uh
no one had predicted like
people like uh paul krugman were saying
that when trump gets in the economy is
gonna tank no uh the economy hit new
highs all right but but but there are so
many people among the intel
intelligentsia especially who are
absolutely immune to facts it's just as
if this is if they took their uh
anti-fat shots uh every every every year
and uh the facts will just not affect
them so this brings us back
i can understand i mean i really can't
my understanding is limited which is why
i'm going to put this in the form of a
question i can understand the never
trumpers who don't
don't bother me with economic boom
because this man is on my television
screen every single night and i can't
stand him i can understand i can see
that impulse i can i can understand what
this is the second consecutive president
united states that i automatically turn
off when i'm watching talk on television
all right keep the remote right next to
your hands okay who was the first obama
got it
uh you're totally bipartisan in that
regard
no other way
but the great society the larger point
that you've been making here the great
society the war on poverty
this is now six
decades of experience yes and we have as
you have said the gap hasn't closed
we've got
dissolution of the family structure
rising crime rates that i don't
understand
how can it be
that
the people
now i don't know how to remain
bipartisan but democrats liberals the
progressives
just are not
the evidence is in this has not worked
like after half more than half a century
there's still a refusal to look at the
evidence
yes and then and there's even a tendency
to falsify the evidence
and how come
i think people become uh
attached to a vision
and uh that really warps the way they
see the
human beings have an enormous capacity
to rationalize
yeah all right
again notes on the passing scene an
article from the new york times just a
couple of days ago quote now this is the
longest quotation but it's important to
lay out the facts here over the last
decade the charter school movement
gained significant foothold in new york
the movement hoped to set a national
example if charter schools could make it
in a deep blue state like new york they
could make it anywhere
over a hundred thousand students in the
in in the city's charter schools are
doing well on state tests and tens of
thousands are on waiting lists but the
election the election of this november
suggested that the golden era of charter
schools is over
the insurgent democrats democrats did
well across new york but especially in
the state senate have repeatedly
expressed hostility to the movement
close quote and tom saw all resources do
you know what charter schools are
okay so in the u.s i don't how does the
education system work here how do they
pick what school you go to
secondary school based on whatever you
live in
it's basically
here so that's the way it is in the us
too it's based on where you're born
which i think is really unfair because i
think that
people that are poor it's not their
fault they're poor right so if you're in
a shitty school district i don't think
you should be
forced to go there
so a charter school is basically
in the city of chicago the last time i
checked they get 13 000 per kid
like that's that's what the state pays
per child that's at your school
and that the charter school would
basically say
that
you can take that money and give it to
any school you want
in the state
so if you want to drive if you can get
your kid out an hour away to get away
from the shitty schools or 30 minutes 20
minutes whatever it is you can pick that
school and they lose the money and give
it to another school
okay so it makes them
be a little bit more competitive for
students
and the an example i use the reason i
use the 13 000 from the city of chicago
is i went to catholic school for 12
years
and they our tuition was around eight
grand a year
okay okay and so that we had less money
and had better results than the public
schools in our area
even though overall the school had less
money
why is that
because people are using the money
correctly yeah and so
yeah so that's we're going to talk a
little bit about it you'll see close
quote and tom saul responds to that set
of facts how
oh
that that really is one of the moral
outrages
that for many kids
who cut from a very poor background and
who parents may not have had much
education a decent education is the one
thing they have to have
to have a better life
and these schools have been absolutely
uh spectacular
uh the charter schools the charter
schools
the successful ones now there are a few
that weren't
but
for example a few years ago
on the statewide new york statewide math
test
there was an elementary school grade 4 i
believe
in harlem
which whose students passed those tests
at a higher rate than any fourth grade
kids anywhere in the state of new york
i mean we're talking scarsdale
briarcliff places like that
the success academy schools as a whole
their students
pass
both the math and the english statewide
tests
at a higher rate than any school system
school district
in the entire state of new york
uh
the vast majority of the kids in the
success academy schools are either black
or hispanic
if you look at the five
highest scoring
district school districts in the state
in terms of the percentage of the
students who passed the math or the
english test
their average family income
ranges from
[Music]
four to four times that
of the kids in the success academy
schools to more than nine times
the family income of the kids and the
academies such as academy schools
and yet the mayor of new york is doing
his darndest
to to to put a stop to the expansion
of
schools in general but
his special ire is aimed at the success
academy schools and this is happening
all over the country because they make
the you the teachers unions look bad
that run the public schools
what what's the political motivation why
would mayor de blasio have an out for
the charter schools such as success
academy well the teachers union are the
major reasons
uh and the we're talking about the the
money they contribute the number of
votes they contribute
uh
and
the schools and what and what's
happening again not just in new york but
in other parts of the country including
california
is that the they they they have all
there's all kind of chicanery uh to
prevent the charter schools from
expanding that's why you have tens of
thousands on the waiting list it's not
that the charter school is not willing
to expand but every conceivable obstacle
is put in their way
because
if you let that go at the natural pace
it would be very hard for the public
schools to compete
and one of the things they're doing is
imposing the same kinds of restrictions
on the on on the charter schools that
that made this public school so bad for
example restrictions on being able to
get rid of kids who are
running a muck and
ruining the education of everybody else
and the charter schools don't tolerate
that
uh the things that are tolerated in the
public schools are unbelievable
uh
so when i asked you a moment ago how do
we bring back the
the state did you go to public school
yeah was it wild i don't know what the
uk is like i was one of the wild kids
yeah yeah you would have been the one
that kicked out i was the way that i was
i was the bad kid but
i was fortunate enough that although i
was wild
i was still smart enough for the basic
level to do well to because um it's very
expensive to expel the kid in from a
public school you have to pay a lot of
money so it's like a last resort
you have to be super bad and that was my
very very last one but what kept me was
the fact that i could contribute to the
school doing better overall in terms of
grades
um so yeah public schools a while but
yeah it's crazy
yeah i've heard some stories
like catholic school we're chilling i
know some catholic schools i know what
y'all say in the comments
about catholic schools
it wasn't no it wasn't like that we were
children
i that's
that's what i've heard about the
catholics
they need they crave attention so much
that they just got off the rails yeah i
i don't know we were
like we were chilling like i barely
drank in high school like i didn't drink
till the last like maybe six months
where like the public schools my friends
are drinking at like 15 though
yeah this is normal yeah it's the worst
of the worst that congregate in the same
area
he's like as long as you literally bring
especially come from
a poverty stricken background you don't
come from the best um home circumstances
for me school wasn't like as freedom it
was a way to get away from home and just
act out and be crazy but when i got home
i was strict and which is good because i
needed that discipline but for a lot of
people he didn't have that discipline
that they just didn't give a doubt about
nothing said they would go they would
while out just do crazy things like
people would throw chairs that teach we
had so many teachers leave and cry
that teacher would cry teachers would
legitimately
do you think they should get rid of
those students
in hindsight of course yeah and i was
dead it was funny
but like don't you think they would act
better if they knew they'd get kicked
out
yeah people need to understand this
consequence of reactions and for a lot
of the kids that did get kicked out they
went to this thing called unit
and it was
if anything it made them even worse
because what they did was that
obviously the normal kids were what were
the kids still in public when other
schools were still doing the gcses but
they would make things even easier um
i don't try as much
so a lot of these kids are saying okay
worse like you know they don't turn up
or they skive
and a lot a lot of them turn to the
streets you see the young girls get
pregnant and the guys end up in jail and
i was just it was a cyclical situation
um so yeah in hindsight those kids
as early as possible should be kicked
out
to not only give the kids in the school
a chance but to give them a second
chance at success well and then also
when they talk about the
they
rally so hard against charter schools in
the us and it's really sad because i
think that that's the biggest um
way that they keep keep poor people poor
okay
because everyone has the right to an
education i think yes they should have
access to a quality education i don't
think it's fair that just because i was
born to a well-off family that i should
get a good education but my friend down
the street can't right i think and it
doesn't make sense because again my
tuition was cheaper than what the public
schools get
and so it's like what are they doing
with this money
and one of the issues is that on the us
we have pension programs so a lot of it
was like 50
of the money goes to teachers that
aren't teaching anymore that didn't
teach them ever like why is that fair
and it's it's at the cost of the
children and the politicians want the
votes from the teachers and the teachers
unions have so much power and and
teachers can't get fired in the u.s
it's very hard to fire a teacher
so
like because again it goes back to the
teachers unions and that have political
interest in them see but i think this is
a
byproduct of lazy government because
lazy work a lazy government because in
terms of amazing teachers
i'm talking specifically about the 13
000 it goes to
some of the poorest families in the us i
think to myself if i was poor like
there's two frames of thinking it's like
if you're someone that's cognizant
enough to want a better life for your
kids
you're probably going to give that money
to your kids
for a lot of these people it's all about
making ends meet and then getting 13
grand well it's not in cash
the school gets it not the family all
right so it goes to this directly to
whatever school they pick they're
they're born into okay no they don't get
cash that's all secrets are they getting
them no no so the school takes the money
and half of it goes to the pension
program okay which is which oh that's
yeah yeah that's why yeah and that's
what i'm saying and the reason so then
they're like okay well why can't we move
our students so they try to make charter
schools and they can't take them or
they're making it really hard because
the politicians want the vote from the
teachers
and the teachers want the money from the
pension program they want to keep saying
like making it easy like did you know in
one of thomas sowell's books he rips on
teachers it's so funny they have an iq a
standard deviation lower than the rest
of the population teachers as a whole in
the us
because when you think about it smart
people want to make money of course and
like the way teachers are like they get
three months off in the summer right but
they they don't make a ton of money but
they're like taking care of after where
they if they teach a certain amount of
time they can defeat the pensions
yeah yeah and but smart people like i
i'm someone i think i'd be a really good
teacher like i could teach a course on
youtube but i'm not gonna do it unless
they're paying me money to do it
so like you're gonna get people that
don't want to make money which i would
say don't tend to be as smart because
smart people want to make money mostly
do things and find new help yeah yeah it
makes sense that makes sense like there
was a school in new york that paid all
of its teachers six figures and they got
the best like and the brightest teachers
and they would record all of their
classroom teachings and they after
school they would have to come and they
would give them like feedback on how
they taught the kids and say you did
that wrong you did that and all that
like a lot of teachers quit because they
couldn't handle it but they've got weeds
out the [ __ ] ones yeah that's that's the
same for a lot of the public services so
that even at the police or whatever you
get a higher standard of of of people
when the money goes up
i'm okay with politicians making a lot
of money they're getting money from
random places anyway
so because i think i trust people that
want to make money okay if you're a
politician no think about it in the us
if you go into congress you would make
less money in congress
than you would starting a business or
being a practicing lawyer a lot of the
time they make less money going like
just from the salary alone okay
if we just paid our politicians a lot of
money then they're in it for the money
and they have to do the best job
possible if it's not the money then what
are you in it for power
exactly so i'm saying like i trust
people that want to make money
and if they can do it doing something
they love and getting and they're
incentivized to do a good job praising
isn't intended making money so
synonymous with gaining power it's hard
to separate the two plus i believe that
if if you're saying paid politicians
politicians a lot of money they're doing
that anyway but a lot of them are
substitutious in their agenda and don't
know what they want so
the money is one aspect but the power is
lost with the money well that's what i'm
saying like if if we paid like i'm okay
with politicians being paid more because
i would just rather someone be open and
honest because they get money from other
places anyway but then who's to say that
because obviously
objectively speaking that sounds
perfectly correct but then when you take
into account human emotion
um that's where it starts to get a bit
problematic because cool you pay them a
lot of money also stop them from wanting
even more money like what is
i know i don't know how i would set it
up because i think they determine their
own money like weirdly enough like
congress can vote to give themselves pay
raises
i don't i don't know exactly how it
works but i would like to see some sort
of incentive for them to do a better job
yes so where
they there is it hurts their paycheck if
say unemployment goes down like goes up
in their state or something where it's
like i don't know how i would set it up
but i would like to see them be
incentivized to do a good job i think
all government politicians should be
philosophers should be work philosophers
people who are deep deep deep informed
deep information no no come on
philosophers are crazy exactly they're
always not are they willing to try new
things because yeah but why would you if
it's not broke don't fix it so [ __ ]
that's it that's how that's how it's
better than it's been in all of human
history there's less wars than in all of
human history we have a higher standard
of living than in all of human history
and you want to bring in philosophers
just tear up the system i want
philosophers they think about they
actually think a lot of these
politicians again not businessman
businessmen because they understand even
even the government is a business and
that's weird the more that i like start
a business and start hiring people and
stuff i'm like i understand that you
can't have too many handout programs
yeah like because it's the same way like
if i have this many people like i have
to make sure they're they're returning
my investment of course otherwise like
otherwise i literally can't pay them and
so it's like when you're in business and
makes you understand like it's weird but
my dad explains that two dollars and one
dollar out you can only have so many of
those programs
and that's the problem is like a lot of
politicians don't know how to balance a
budget
csa business people should should cover
the world i mean that's honestly why
trump did a good job he was a
businessman yeah i hear it i hear it
because yeah they have experience in
managing things on that level and
managing people like there should be
businessmen and philosophers yes okay
you can you can die on that i think
there needs to be an element of
philosophy in not not obviously that the
like the plato's but there needs to be
an element of actual thinking where a
lot of these guys are just driven by
moon and moon i think it should be about
money
i think a combination of the two
so when i asked you a moment ago how do
we bring back the
the standards of the harlem in which you
grew up the answer is that's a hard
thing to do but we do know how to do one
thing we do know how to establish
schools where the kids in present-day
harlem have a shot they have a chance of
getting a good idea you don't have to
bring back the past
even if you could
uh uh because we have it in the present
we have to we have this happening and so
we know how to do that and the
democratic establishment in new york
wants to shut it down yes
and the republican establishment stands
mute stands mute
you know i love talking to you but i
really don't know why it's all
it's all discouraging tom you mentioned
again a moment ago the um
the way young americans
uh
flocked to bernie sanders gallup poll
this summer the proportion of americans
age 18 to 29
that holds a favorable view of
capitalism 45
the proportion that holds a favorable
view of socialism 51
now i would like you to take a look at a
brief video of alexandria ocasio-cortez
who at the age of 29 calling herself a
democratic socialist has just been
elected to the house of representatives
from new york and although she's not
seated yet in the new congress she went
to washington and one of her first acts
was to participate in a sit-in
in the offices
of house majority leader nancy pelosi
that is to say her the leader of her own
party yes so here's a brief
i just want to let you video know how
proud i am
of each and every single one of you for
putting yourselves and your body and and
everything on the line to make sure that
we save our planet our generation and
our future
it's so incredibly important
we have to get to 100 renewable energy
in 10 years there is no other option
tom
to her supporters to the supporters of
bernie sanders to young americans what
would you say
i would say
get some facts first know what you're
talking about before you start spouting
out this kind of stuff
asked one of the things i do in a new
new book as i suggest that uh
uh there's a certain uh opinion about
what happened in the 1920s where the
taxes were cut from the highest tax rate
was cut down from 73 to 24
and the argument was this is tax cuts
for the rich and i have suggested that
the students and that uh the secretary
of the treasury did this in in support
of us trickle down theory and so forth
and i suggested that the student will be
a wonderful project to go read what the
secretary of the treasury actually said
andrew mellon in the 1920s yeah these
tax cuts and then
go on the internet and get the uh
internal revenue official
data on who paid how much taxes in the
1920s
and it turns out if you do that you find
that andrew mellon said the exact
opposite of what he has attributed
is attributed to him in textbooks that
have been
sold widely for decades on end through
successive uh uh
additions
and what you'll find is that in the
and when the tax rate was at 73
uh the people who are making over a
hundred thousand dollars a year and
that's maybe a couple of million in
today's money
uh paid 30 percent of the taxes
and after the so-called tax cuts for the
rich
they paid 65 percent of all the taxes
and the people with incomes under five
thousand dollars which is also was a
nice income in those days
uh who were paying uh 15
when the tax rate was
was uh cut
before the tax check was cut and after
it was cut they paid just under a
quarter of one percent of all the taxes
and so we hear how and so there's all
kinds of indignation in these scholarly
books we're not talking about just
political propaganda
uh how this this was a bonanza for the
rich and so on and uh people with
ordinary incomes paid practically
nothing in income tax after the tax cuts
and though and millionaires uh the share
of millionaires was uh i think four
percent before that and and it was 19
afterwards
uh and but but the facts simply do not
matter
they they say these words they say
trickle down and it's like saying
abracadabra
and and all the miraculous things follow
from that
tom soul author of a forthcoming edition
of discrimination and disparities would
you close
by reading a brief quotation from your
1987 book one of my favorites a conflict
of visions
logic of course is not the only test of
a theory
empirical evidence is crucial
and yet social visions have shown a
remarkable ability to evade suppress or
explain away discordant evidence
historic evasions of evidence are a
warning not a model
dedication to a cause may legitimately
entail sacrifices of personal interest
but not sacrifices of mind or conscience
dr thomas sol thank you thank you
for uncommon knowledge
the hoover what'd you think my dude so
it was good first of all i record the
book i was talking about when i was
talking about the banking thing it was a
book by randy edward lodge why i stopped
talking to white people about race and
it wasn't like and it wasn't an analysis
it was a good texture analysis sounds
like about it it's a great book because
it's a contextual analysis of the racism
in um
in the uk there's a lot of stuff that we
really tend to go to was america so she
wanted to give her an analysis of
what racism in the uk looked like that's
what i was referencing so you can find
that in that book if you wanted to okay
okay yeah look at it what else what did
you think about what he said about the
tax cuts i already knew that um but
again
it's interesting how again there's a
misrepresentation of the information um
a lot of times we tend to think that
these things do benefit the rich and
he's
this is obviously u.s specific
um the uk this is
they put a similar narrative but um it's
not something that's really readily
available and i think the fact that
people tend to assume that a lot of the
taxes are paid by people with lower
income brackets
excuse their opinion of what would
actually be beneficial for them in the
long run in terms of their governmental
vote well and it makes sense too because
like trickle-down theory isn't actually
real but what they mean is like
like if i make more money i just
reinvest it and i hire new people yes
i'm tired tired of doing this stuff by
myself send money
send money
but you know what i mean and so most
people that are like passionate about
their business that's what they spend
their money on growing it yeah
yeah
so you know you don't think the trickle
down theory is legitimate well it's not
a real theory they just say that to
discredit republicans but like you can't
find a single economist that's ever said
that theory thomas soul even says he'd
pay someone five thousand dollars you
give him one economist
because there's something that often
heard the masters as well to trickle
down theory
and and how yeah things will come down
from the topic for x ex-wise it happens
but i never looked into it too deeply
but i just assumed that i was a real
thing since i heard it so much yeah but
i think that's that's part of the
problems these
assumptions they're not based on any
academic or peer-reviewed facts that can
be come back from quite problematic but
it's spouted in
like you know news channels or
propaganda campaigns well and the other
problem is the the academic the at like
academic
people are so left
that a lot of even like data is skewed
and a lot of like um
there was a guy
who
this was funny actually
he got a paper published about how like
dogs were sexist where he completely
made up the data and it was supposed to
be like a very high academic in the
comments let me know where this was but
it was it was something about the sexism
of like dogs and it just it it followed
the left agenda and the left
narrative and it got published and it
was a joke and he none of it was even
real she's made it up yeah and that's
like how many of these
places are really checking the sources
yeah as long as it meets it suits
yeah idealism then it's okay to put it
out there spread this
yeah these lies yeah
so how are you conservative yet
if i had to say percentage-wise i would
say
i i'm a higher percentage in terms of
conservative because i really had
conservative values and views i just
mixed them into my library and then i
marketed myself as a liberal
but now i think um
i can officially call myself um
a conservative in the majority of
conversations not one of them in a
mature conversation
and you played a hefty part in that you
corrupted me
that's well that's what we do
so guys um let us know in the comments
what you want us to react to next also
go follow the domino effect podcast
uh the link will be in the description
and you're also going to comment on this
video yes yes yes so um the episode that
i'm in is going to be dropping in like
two weeks two or three weeks so might
come out next week i'll double check the
rest though okay that better be on the
topic oh [ __ ] yeah that was just
professional we did it we did a
we do but listen if you're from the uk
and you watch um just early things hit
me up as well because if you want to get
on the show and engage in these
conversations hit my dm's eyeball go to
the um there's the pre-game i'll put
your i'll link your ig in the
description yes hit me up message me
yeah he's a recruiter now you'll get
into the show i'm here yeah i mean the
show's about to go listen it's been
their bits
okay guys like the video subscribe to
the channel and we'll talk to you next
time peace out